we all know the story of mowgli from
rudyard kipling's the jungle book about
the boy who was brought up by wolves
or edgar rice burrows tarzan who was
raised by chimpanzees
and then there's the story of romulus
and remus
the founders of rome suckled by a wolf
in a cave
but
can humans really be raised by animals
and if so
how would they adapt to society
this is your body on being raised by
animals
feral children are children who don't
have interactions with other humans
there are about 4 000 accounts of feral
children that are considered reliable
sadly most of these cases are due to
neglect
here are three incredible stories of
humans raised by animals
raised by monkeys marina chapman
this is marina chapman in 2012
she published a book about being raised
by monkeys in the jungles of colombia
in 1950 when she was a young child
chapman was abandoned in a forest
she almost died until a family of
capuchin monkeys led her to fruit and
nuts the monkeys took her in and
protected her but she still had to fend
for herself taking food when she could
when she was about nine years old she
was discovered by people who sadly sold
her into domestic slavery
she ran away and lived on the streets
where she learned to speak and use her
jungle skills to survive
eventually she was able to conform to
modern society and even married and had
children
raised by wolves marcos rodriquez
pantoja
this is marcos pantoja
after losing his mother at an early age
marcos suffered an abusive upbringing
from his stepmother
at the age of six his father sold him to
a goat farmer in a remote area of the
sierra morena mountain range in spain
when the farmer died two years later
marcos was left to fend for himself
while exploring the mountains for food
marcos came across a wolf cub in a cave
after playing with the cub he fell
asleep and woke later to find the mother
growling and baring her teeth at him
marcos backed away
after feeding her cubs the mother
offered some of the leftover meat to the
boy
from then on
marcos lived as a member of the wolf
pack
for 12 years
he was found by spanish civil guards who
bound and gagged him to keep him from
howling they took him home to his father
wanting nothing to do with marcos his
father took him to a hospital run by
nuns
there he was taught to speak walk
upright dress properly and eat with
cutlery
the feral upbringing left marcos
traumatized
he fought with the nuns when they tried
to get him to sleep in a bed and he
feared he was being attacked during his
first haircut
after serving in the military and
working with a pastor for many years
marcos struggled to adapt to modern
society
feeling isolated he returned to the
mountains to live with the animals
unfortunately his wolf family rejected
him because of his human scent
raised by dogs oksana malaya
this is oksana malaya
in 1991 at the age of three
she was left outside by her alcoholic
parents
she crawled into a dog kennel for
shelter and warmth
oksana spent the next five years with
the dogs where she ate scraps left by
the animals a neighbor noticed her at
eight years old living in the kennel
she ran on all fours barked like a dog
panted with her tongue out and would
bare her teeth
she couldn't talk
can't talk once a child passes the age
of five without learning to talk it's
almost impossible for them to learn to
speak normally can you say hello oksana
however did speak before she was
abandoned and was able to re-learn how
to communicate
it took six months to suppress her
dog-like behavior
now an adult she's able to speak and
eats with her hands instead of lapping
up her food with her tongue
but she still has moments when she goes
back to her feral upbringing like
crawling on all fours when she feels
lonely
it's estimated that she has the mental
capacity of a six-year-old
now that we've seen that feral children
are real
we'll discover if humans can have super
powers
on another episode of your body on
you